nun aber zur Nachricht der Woche die
Ampel hat eine Klima
außenpolitikstategie ja ja ihr wisst
doch gar nicht was das ist was aber
sicher ist damit kann die Frau bärbock
jetzt tierisch angeben beim Klimagipfel
in Dubai es darf dann nur bitte keiner
nachfragen wie es mit unserer
Energiewende läuft z.B bei den E-Autos
sagen wir mal suboptimal ja nicht so
doll von den 15 Millionen Stroman die
laut Koalitionsvertrag 2030 auf
deutschen Straßen fahren sollen wurden
bislang 1,3 Millionen zugelassen ja gut
reine Elektrofahrzeuge sind bei uns eben
längst noch nicht Alltag würden sie sich
auch ein E-Auto zunhen haben sie habe
ich ja ja ja
tatsächlich und das ist also nur für
Sonntags ja klar natürlich es gibt
sonntagsautos Montagsautos jeden Tag ein
frisches Fahrzeug wie bei den Unterhosen
ne warum nicht im November sind
22,5% weniger E-Autos neu zugelassen
worden als im Vorjahresmonat und ich
sage kein Wunder damals zum
Jahreswechsel wurde die statliche
Förderung von 6000 auf 4500 € gesenkt ab
Januar 24 sind es dann nur noch 3000 für
eAutos die maximal 45 000 € Kosten und
dann ist auch noch die Subvention für
elektrische Dienstwagen ausgelaufen auch
das wirkt sich aus hier Olaf Scholz
diese Woche bei BMW wie immer grundlos
optimistisch wer hier Produktion sieht
und die ganzen Veränderung begleiten
kann der geht hier weg mit dem sicheren
Gefühl das wird uns gelingen das wird
unser Land schaffen wie der Umstieg zur
eobilität künftig durch die Politik
gefördert wird dazu schwiegt der Kanzler
natürlich Olaf Scholz noch leiser als
ein
E-Auto übrigens haben die Hersteller
sich längst vom 15 Millionen Ziel für
2030 verabschiedet 9 Millionen
vielleicht sagen die vielleicht muss
jetzt nur noch irgendwer dem
Verkehrsminister Wissing beibringen ne
gut letzte Woche war war wieder
e-autoogipfel im Kanzleramt schon der
zweite Gipfel in diesem Jahr eingeladen
waren da VW BMW Mercedes
Wirtschaftsverbände und Achtung kein
Vertreter von Umwelt und
Verbraucherverbänden klar die Nerven ja
auch ne
angeblich gibt's auf der Rückseite vom
Kanzleramt sogar einen
drchalter für Vertreter der Autolobby
der ist ständig
besetzt also pass auf ich nehme einmal
180 als Mindestgeschwindigkeit für
Landstraßen und eine viel fettere
Kaufprämie für Elektroautos aber nur für
Porsche hast du all mitgeschrieen ja
dann bis morgen ne
Ciao voll praktisch und wie schön dass
der Kanzler sich dafür die Zeit nimmt
oderit des Gipfels man fordert mehr
ladesäollen und man fordert mehr
bezahlbare E-Autos kann man fordern laut
adrc gibt es hier aktuell nur drei
e-automodelle für unter 30.000 €
darunter kein deutscher Hersteller
unsere Autofirmen haben viel zu lange
gezögert bei der E-Mobilität ja
Grundlagenforschung
verpennt woanders ist man viel weiter
wissen sie ne in China ist es ein
Massenmarkt massiv subventioniert in
Frankreich gibt's bald EA Leasing für
100 € im Monat und in Norwegen werden
schon ab
2025 gar keine Verbrenner mehr
zugelassen ja da waren letztes Jahr
schon vier von fünf Neuwagen elektrisch
wie machen die das es gibt eine einfache
Antwort auf die Frage warum wir in
Norwegen so erfolgreich sind und das
sind die Ökosteuern wir besteuern das
was wir nicht wollen nämlich Autos mit
fossilen Brennstoffen und wir fördern
das was wir wollen nämlich Elektroautos
so einfach ist das so einfach ist das
blöde norwegischeer Angeber du ja war
übrigens ein Vorschlag vom
Umweltbundesamt auch bei uns Verbrenner
zu verteuern ja gewagte Idee wo der
deutsche eh das Gefühl hat erzogen zu
werden trotzdem müssen die Hersteller
sich jenseits von Staatshilfen mal
dringend was überlegen was einfallen
lassen in China liegt der Marktanteil
von Audi Mercedes und BMW jeweils bei
unter
1% warum weil man zu lange auf große
protzkarren gesetzt hat da fällt mir ein
kennen Sie schon den Tesla
cybertruck ein von Elon Musk
erschaffenes Auto Monster 3 Tonn schwer
ein absurder estraßenpanzer aus dickem
Edelstahl potässlich aber schusssicher
warum auch immer weiß nicht wofür man
das braucht ja ja die versuchen jetzt
wirklich Greta Thunberg als Werbegesicht
zu kriegen dann brettert die mit dem
cybertruck zum nächsten Weltklimagipfel
mit 50 PS und wer weiß vielleicht hat
der Irre Elon ja recht vielleicht lassen
sich Hardcore verbrennerfans nur so fürs
E-Auto begeistern
endlich ein Spielzeug für richtige Jungs
der Tesla cybertruck 5 kg schwer und aus
echte Metall dieser Truck geht nicht
kaputt er macht kaputt denn er hat
messerscharfe Kanten dein Dover Bruder
spielt lieber mit der Holzeisenbahn dann
zeigt der ökobratze mal wo beim
cybertruck der Hammer
[Musik]
hol dir jetzt den cybertruck von Tesla
inklusive drei klimakleber zum
überfahren geil der cybertruck was für
eine
[Musik]
idiotenkar
ja vielleicht lassen
sich hentlich
nichtuschauer buchstäblich Preisfrage
warum kostet ein E-Auto in Deutschland
im Schnitt immer noch 10 bis 12% mehr
als ein Verbrenner gegenfrage warum
verlangen szenerestaurants für einen
verkochten Kürbis mit Bulgur über 40 €
weil sie es können weil es genug reiche
Gutmenschen gibt die sich ihr gutes
Gewissen was kosten lassen ja na gut
überteuerte Autos aber dafür Speicher
beim E-Auto Laden denkt der Leihe
tatsächlich liegen die Lade Reise an
öffentlichen Säulen irgendwo zwischen
Benzin und Diesel und dann ist da
natürlich das gelade auch noch sehr
intransparent und super kompliziert es
gibt mehr als 2000 Betreiber mit total
unterschiedlichen ladekarten oder
bezahlapps deprimierender funf am Rande
jede zweite deutsche Kommune hat keine
einzige öffentliche Ladesäule plus das
Problemchen mit den Verteilernetzen den
stromverteilernetzen von denen einige
auf zu viele E-Autos gar nicht
vorbereitet sind wir haben hier so die
typischen einfilienhausstraßen die mal
als neubgebiet ausgewiesen worden sind
vor ich sag mal 25 Jahren vor 15 Jahren
haben wir noch eins gehabt so wenn da
jeder zweite sich ein E-Auto anschaffen
würde dann könnten die ander nicht mehr
Fernseh
gucken oft läuft ja eh nur Scheiße dann
ruft man aus dem Fenster Manfred hör mal
auf deine Karre zu laden ich will mir
ein Sandwich
toasten tatsächlich ein unterschätztes
Problem deutschen Verteilernetze müssten
dringend ausgebaut werden für all die
E-Autos und Wärmepumpen leider dauern
die Genehmigungsverfahren für sowas im
Moment zwischen 8 und 12 Jahre neueste
Notlösung bei Überlastung dürfen die
Netzbetreiber den Strom für Wärmepumpen
und E-Autos rationieren also
runterdrosseln gleichzeitig müssen
deutsche Hausbesitzer intelligente
Stromzähler einbauen ab 2030 sollen alle
so einen Smart Mieter haben hurra unser
Netz wird intelligent der Smart Meta
boah unsere beste Anschaffung ever was
man da spart wenn Zähler und Ladegerät
intelligent sind alles verletzt deswegen
LT z.B genau jetzt gerade mein E-Auto
weil ich dann in den günstigeren Tarif
komme geil sag mal wir wollten noch
jetzt zu deiner Mutter fahren stimmt
total
vergessen mama du wir können heute
leider doch nicht kommen mein Auto läd
jetzt voll schade und und wir hatten uns
so gefreut auf deinen leckeren
Stollen aber ist ja nicht schlimm wir
sehen uns einfach nächstes Weihnachten
ja ja genau wenn du da noch lebst ja m
alles klar ciao ciao
ciao
hä was geht nicht an ist sie kaputt oder
was nein die ist smart also wesentlich
smarter als du jedenfalls und deswegen
weißt die auch dass Strom um diese
Uhrzeit viel zu teuer ist
manchmal die ermler können trotzdem
schnell herausfinden dass es sich bei
der
Affäre Alexander lass die Kühlschranktür
nicht so lange auf wir haben
klimawandelch
das smarte hausystem spricht seit heute
mit der Big Brother stimme ich weiß auch
nicht warum hast du de Problem mit nein
nein nein überhaupt
nicht schön Abend zu
Hause diese Sendung ist viel zu doof für
ein smartes Netz ich schalte jetzt auf
dre
interessüberm
[Musik]
wir gehen mal ganz kurz in den
Garten hier kann uns das smartmer nicht
hören pass auf du du gehst jetzt rein
und du lenst es ab indem du viel zu
lange dich föhnst und ich gehe runter in
den Keller und den ganz scheiß wieder
aus alles
klar
was das Schloss ist ausgetauscht das war
ich ihr verbraucht zu viel Energie
deshalb wohnt ihr nicht mehr hier haut
ab Hallo
bei euch
auch
scheiße Smartmeter ist es zu klug seid
ihr zu
doof nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den Kanal abonniert und
ein Like da
lasst
ich habe die Schnauze
voll ja los lasst ein Abo
da